impossible de la louper si vous passez
du côté du quai d'austerlitz à paris et
la cité de la mode ne laisse personne
indifférent avec sa couleur vert fluo
les travaux se terminent avec plusieurs
mois de retard on découvre en
avant-première ce nouveau lieu avec la
croix et noé salem
certains l'ont baptisé le bobo vers
d'autres nettement moins séduit le
lézard le serpent ou le truc vert cette
structure d'acier et de verre stratifié
suspendu en bord de seine va abriter un
nouveau lieu de promenade pour les
parisiens de là ils pourront accéder à
l'institut de la mode des commerces et
même un restaurant mais pourquoi ce ver
le faire c'est parce que d'une part la
scène allait pas bleu et c'est un peu un
projet qui est vraiment celle qui
s'inspirait des fûts de la scène hasan a
quand même fait une couleur verdâtre
c'est en moi une expérience spatiale que
vous pouvez voir ici avec toute la
structure qui se déploie qui rentrent
qui en sort on a un jeu d'ombré et de
lumière à travers les verres
sérigraphiés cet édifice spacieux 14
mille mètres carrés répartis sur trois
niveaux jouit même d'une terrasse qui
sera végétalisé et de laquelle on devine
déjà une vue dégagée de paris elle sera
accessible au public le jour jusque tard
dans la nuit mais pas avant l'automne
le chantier a pris plusieurs mois de
retard ce chantier a été ouvert en
décembre 2006 et l'a donc eu deux hivers
nous comptons 60 jours d'intempéries qui
fait déjà près de trois mois de travail
ce chantier de 40 millions d'euros est
aujourd'hui en cours de finition avec la
pose d'un et des parcs et sur les
espaces publics
prochaine étape cet été l'installation
des futurs occupants
les franciliens devront attendre le mois
d'octobre pour y déambuler où il y
assister à des défilés de mode